[Music]
priscila I know that you spoke at the
Women's League inaugural luncheon and I
was struck by your commenting on three
things that were very important in your
role as wife of the president do you
remember what they were what you talked
about no I probably don't you see you
searched my memory
well you said a sense of yourself in a
sense of humor and a love of people and
I thought that was it do you want to
talk a little bit about each of those
yes Sarah heuristics I think that
probably a sense of self is absolutely
crucial otherwise you you are smothered
by the job you you have to have to know
yourself pretty well and be comfortable
with yourself and then go on from there
a sense of humor I can't imagine if I
couldn't have laughed at all the
ridiculous things that went on how we
would have gotten through and what was
that her love of the people the love of
people I'm glad it's unpacked it's a
simple job it really is a people job and
we kept track when you we never did it
again because it was almost overwhelming
to know but we kept track one year and I
believe we fed real food to something
like 999 thousand people and you know
just under ten thousand people and
that's a lot of people in a place that
is your home as well as the Institute
home yeah well I want to pick up on that
what about home in the first place going
to a sense of yourself do you want to
talk a little bit about what your issue
was of the job when he found out that
Paul was going to become president you
want to talk a little bit about that
what that was like in terms of thinking
about yourself well it was it was really
learn as we went that first year it was
a great change for me
Edythe my children were pretty well
grown Weezy was the only one that was at
home you have fortunately we have four
children
Weezy was a 16 year old and so she was
in and out of our lives there in the
president's house
but fortunately had already gone away to
school and so didn't live in the
fishbowl which I think would have been
hot on a young person we we really did
feel that way along but we hadn't we had
some things that we felt strongly about
we realized very early on that students
came to the President's House in large
part because they were leaders they were
on various committees they were part of
the student government the fraternity
conference they were there because they
were movers and doers among their peers
and it was very easy to say you see the
same group of students and I worried a
lot about that that first year and that
you wonder saying other students you
mean that that was very selective that
it was too selective and so we did two
things we we did a Christmas party where
we really tried very hard to invite
students from all over campus that
weren't leaders ones that we'd met up
with in in a variety of ways and we
looked for about
a hundred young people that worked well
and that was fun and but it wasn't
consistent consistent again we needed a
mechanism where we felt as if sometime
during the four years everyone had a
chance to be in the house and sit down
and have dinner with Paul and me and so
we devised the senior dinners and we
invited the whole senior class and that
first February we made lots of mistakes
we invited them and we tried for
weekends we tried for brunches we tried
for kind of picnic indoor picnic style
Saturday afternoon parties we tried a
variety of things and we learned what
worked and what didn't they don't like
to get up early in the morning a brunch
was not popular Saturday afternoon was
not popular there were athletic s-- we
also decided because we were working
with a limited budget that we would
serve the same thing then people
wouldn't be worrying that they had
so-and-so came on a chicken night and
somebody else got fish so he did lasagna
and at the end of four weeks of lasagna
Paul and I he I don't think looked at
designer for another five years so we
went into the second year much more
prepared
it was a Monday through Thursday
proposition and coming away from
weekends we kept away from weekends all
together because it's a lot of work to
set up and have no one come all have
half of the people you're ready for come
and we found that about 70 he came for
each night out of a hundred or so
invitations yes well the whole class was
invited
and they were given a postcard with
dates and they could select three
choices and then they were divided up
divided up the first year we asked too
many alumni the idea being that the
alumni would talk about what they done
what their interests were why these
young people should keep in touch with
the Alumni Association and that pot was
wonderful but too many and just one or
two who got carried away and recited
their life story took away time that we
needed for the freshmen and so we got
that under control and by the second
year we were really in much better shape
were you were you disciplining the
Alumni no we just didn't invite as many
we invited a numbers of it every table
would have one or two and we we were
very specific about what we wanted them
to talk about and how long we wanted
them to talk we did not talk a lot about
what we were going to do at the end of
the seniors in this but we asked each
young person to stand up talk about
where they came from what they had done
at MIT and what they hope to do next and
it really was fascinating I think that
they would have been very put off by
that hearing about it ahead of time
right but by the time that moment came
it was a very natural thing and they
just went around the room and there was
some there was some marvelous evenings
one young person one one year got up and
said he lived he lived just off exit 95
on the Garden State Parkway in New
Jersey and so then all around the room
all the exits off route such-and-such
were mentioned and we would we had some
mild asthma so it sounds like MIT with
its fixation on numbers you know of
course whatever exit
it was interesting to see the emphasis
begin to swing towards some public
service jobs to much more teaching I
think when we first started the first
two or three years we didn't have a
single senior interested in teaching and
by our last year we had five or six
interested and I'm in the process right
now of reading applicants applications
for fellowships for the public service
center for teaching fellowships in I ap
and were overwhelmed and and the problem
is that they're all qualified we we just
advise everyone that I want to come back
to that but I want to go backwards for a
few minutes and pick up on some of the
things you mentioned first I'm struck by
the fact that you the pronoun you use
all the time is we and would you talk
about the the we aspects of the job what
if one of the really hard things when
you're doing a job like that is to
define who you are and what you're
called and the general feeling is that
oh you don't work you don't have a
salary and my response was follow me for
a day and then decide whether or not I
work but it was a partnership mm-hmm and
it was a full-time job and it took two
of us uh-huh would you talk about about
what other ways and what
you I mean what were some of the did you
did Paul use you for example as a
sounding board when major issues were
coming up at the Institute is there some
can you talk a little bit about that
some of the issues that arose or that
were particular I hear one of the
aspects that I'm stuck with is the
concern about involving the community
and where there are other ways in which
you saw that as an issue for the two of
you to work on yes I think the will I
think there were several issues that we
just sort of always had on the back
burner you know two people always see
things from a different perspective and
I think we helped each other to sort out
what our priorities were I know that
when there was a death on the campus for
instance of someone who we had dearly
loved and who was really an MIT figure
dark edge ISM for example we wanted so
much at the time of that memorial
service to gather the people that were
taking part together for Esther so that
she could meet them all in a in a
setting and where it would be less
formal and where she wouldn't have to be
standing around and that worked well
they have it at the president's house
and that was one of those things that we
decided to do and then it was it was my
responsibility to make it happen those
kinds of things just naturally fell fell
so it was the kind of humane
and personal dimension apropos of that I
remember seeing you one day in a very
touching situation when Doc Edgerton was
giving a speech do you want to talk
about that and he lost his place do you
want to talk about what went through to
describe that a little bit because I
found that a very moving moment in your
role well he lost his place was a major
event I forgot what it was the it was
the department's anniversary birthday
party if you will
anniversary celebration and he had put
down his notes and those that he had
already used somehow got put back on the
top of the pile so he was going back to
the very beginning and we were well
beyond halfway through the program I was
next to him
and I was next to the podium and it was
clear from all hand signals and written
messages being slipped to me from the
floor that they needed me to do
something and it was awkward because I
didn't for a minute want to hurt Doc's
feelings but I needed to rescue him and
in the end he gave me the opportunity
because he said I think I'm mixed up
here and I could just grab that section
of paper that he needed to get pulled
away and he then realized what had
happened and he carried on yo cuz I I I
remember thinking what a beautiful
moment that was and how graciously you
had done that he he'd given me he'd
given me that little window of
opportunity which I really needed uh-huh
to do it without hurting his feelings do
you think a man
I hate to make the the gender
distinction but do you think there is a
gender distinction here possibly that a
man would have had a harder time getting
up to do that I don't know I was just in
the right place at the right time and
doc and I had a relationship that went
back to when I was 19 or 20 that was
that well
Paul worked for doc as a TA and so all
the years that we were dating I got to
know him and then we lived near them
when we came back here for graduate
school and dark and Esther were real
mentors as the children came doc would
show up with a camera and Esther would
show up with a casserole perfect company
just just always been a part of our
lives doc and my dad we're exactly the
same age and had some of the similar
profile or an academic no we was not but
they had met once and and Doc I was
asked about him and my dad always asked
about doc and I think there were just
lots of bonds there that made it easier
for me to do what was needed that night
and I don't think it was a gender thing
I think it was just that I happen to be
the right person in the right spot
mm-hmm but but that was certainly a
memorable moment don't thing for
everyone in the audience and your role
was much appreciated and thank you I
know
thank you could you talk a little bit
you referred to the edgington's as
mentors and role models did you have any
role models for your your role as wife
of the president Leia Wiesner Leia and
Jerry have probably been the kinds of
friends and mentors to so many people in
this community that everyone needs but
Jerry was always there with the right
kind of advice for the two of us and
when we were trying to make the decision
in 79-80 about moving into the
president's house
Jerry's advice was just wonderful and
Leia was the one when we decided to make
the move who sort of urged me to do what
I needed to do and get on with it and
make it right so that our children would
feel it was a home and you're talking
about redecorating and and fixing
adopting sort of establishing bedrooms
for the children because after all they
were they were going to be home a lot on
vacations and she just she thought I
needed she had a sense of that family
responsibility and and how much it meant
to me and how much that had been part of
the decision how it would would affect
that was one of the things you worried
about was that as we moved into the role
that you would become necessarily
somewhat distant from involvement with
your children and there was never a time
that I couldn't call Leia and know that
the advice I got was what she honestly
thought the hurry
her reflections on on the questions
posed but he's very very helpful very
kind and right very caring mental uh-huh
so so now they did not move into the
president's house but that's right but
they advised you to on what basis you
want to talk a little bit about that
about that choice that well I guess I
feel very strongly about that as we did
that
the community did not understand that
Leia's physical problems did not lend
themselves to that house remember that
it's just been in the last four years
that there's been any handicapped access
any elevator in that house and Leia was
having terrible problems with stay as
needed to be swimming Jerry had just
built her an indoor pool it was not an
option really for them to move in there
but when when they realized that we
really thought that it might be the
thing for us to do they were very
supportive and very helpful in getting
us started on planning that move mm-hmm
and you had been involved somewhat when
Jerry and Leo were president yourselves
in the administration so that's not Paul
was Jerry's Chancellor uh-huh and so for
we'd worked so closely and for us it was
just just in some ways a continuation
but on campus of some of the things
we've done we tried to do some
entertaining for them in Winchester just
to lighten the burden a little bit for
the weasoner x' for the reason is for
Jerry and Leia right and so every once
in a while when Leia was not feeling
quite up to snuff and and then needed to
be somebody at the house for a function
Jerry would call Anne and Paul and I
would be there mm-hmm
and it worked very very well so you were
really complimentary mm-hm team now was
there a change in your role from the
time Paul was Chancellor to when he
became president
oh yes it's a tremendous change it's a
tremendous change because well then it's
your job before you're asked to help and
you do everything that you can but it's
it's it's much more fun it's much more
up to you to decide whether or not you
do it is that what you're saying that
well I think your helper uh-huh I think
you know ancillary Paul described
himself in those years when he was
Chancellor as Jerry's deputy and I
suppose in the way I was Leia's deputy
you know that's interesting yes I was
available when she when she needed me
now now you talked earlier about people
not thinking of it as work because you
didn't get a salary do you want to talk
who where did you get that sense from
that people didn't understand what the
role was about I think all of us in the
country think about this now in relation
to Hillary Clinton for example and I
think that how do you want to talk a
little bit about that in those 10 years
there was a tremendous tremendous amount
of discussion among college presidents
and their spouses as to what a title
might be people were really searching
for that and it the obvious one just
doesn't spring out yet Edith I finally
signed myself as partner to university
president that was as close as I could
come to an accurate truthful description
I couldn't really put that I didn't work
because I didn't have a life of my own I
really was totally involved here and I
think you will find if you look back
that between 1980 and 1990 that probably
was the title of choice I have not heard
that they've come up with any better one
mm-hmm well it's a it's a difficult role
because you aren't accountable in the in
the same way and yet everyone knows how
significant two people are in a marriage
relationship when one has a job like
that now you say you couldn't were there
ways in which you feel you lost
something of what you might like to have
done on your own had Paul not been
president
I lost a personal life but it I
certainly was part of a very rich
experience in those 10 years I lost the
ability to have any spontaneity in
picking up and doing things and we
learned a lot about our friends some
friends had no patience with with our
life and because I thought they were
being snubbed or excluded in some way I
couldn't believe given 'men an
invitation that could move through a six
week to two month period of time that we
couldn't we couldn't accommodate that
but perhaps could in six months and they
just my children were absolutely
remarkable they they learn to put dates
on the calendar and we absolutely didn't
let things get those dates shoved aside
but they would plan way ahead they would
plan six to eight months ahead which is
not easy for young people they don't
think in those terms you you had
weddings and births and
do you want to talk a little bit about
that those years what had had three
weddings in the president's house and
then one of the one of the people who
worked for us was married in the
president's house and one of Virginia's
college roommates who was who got a PhD
at MIT was married in the president's
house
so Paul used to teasingly say we did
weddings you catered weddings we did
weddings uh-huh and we had we had some
little people in the president's house
yeah I guess remember that we extended
for some some months while they made a
second search for the vests when Phil
sharp changed his mind our oldest
daughter had twins and was very very ill
and went back to the hospital and I
ended up spending six weeks out there
which was where in pomfret Connecticut
with with she already had three children
with those five little girls doing MIT
work over the phone at night and and
trying to keep that household together
days because she went back into the
hospital it was not an easy time but
that that kind of emergency you just
simply have to drop everything and and
put things aside there was no on there's
no scene there was no conflict for you
you knew things where I belonged
yes but there were other times where it
was much less clear and the decisions
were much hotter my dad went downhill
over a period of six or seven weeks the
last two weeks were very clear that he
was slipping away and and I commuted
daily they lived in South Dartmouth and
I commuted daily the first the first
part of that time was a much harder call
because you know it could have been just
another episode and and he might have
pulled out of it
it was hard to know whether you
continually canceled things and what you
did that was when a phone in the cow
just a treasure because I would be stuck
in traffic with a dinner party coming up
fast and nobody know where I was and
when I went to a car phone it really was
a blessing uh-huh so you have very
personal understanding of advanced
technology yes that was technology that
I thought was absolutely marvelous it
was it was there some even Bostick was
so marvelous Wow yes I suspect that I
thought telephone was the enemy but in
not in the house and and in in the
you're constantly available you mean you
that's right that's right
right but in the car it did work for us
I wanted to you have gone you talked
about so many issues that reflect so
much of what has happened to women over
the period of time and I know that the
role of women at MIT was always a major
issue during Paul's administration do
you want to talk about that and what you
have seen over the period of time you've
been oh I believe this year that the
freshman class has 42% women in it and
it's it's such a profound difference
because I've been around here for so
long
that I can remember classes where you
had to really look for them and now
they're everywhere and I think that's
absolutely wonderful I think they're
doing well I think Becky vest has
continued the open houses for women at
the beginning of the term I suspect all
freshmen have some homesickness but I
think some of the young women
had had problems where they needed just
a little extra special nurturing and I
think that afternoon with with just
themselves coming into the President's
House and being able to meet as a class
was perhaps helpful I'm so pleased
because I think she has continued to do
that mm-hmm
now what about when you look at your own
role and your daughters and your
daughter and law what's your feeling
about the way their lives may or may not
be like yours and could you visualize
one of them and your partner role well
yes I am a daughter actually whose life
is very much like mine she's married to
a headmaster of a small private school
and does a great many things that I have
done through the issue does a great deal
of entertaining she really is
is the partner one of the big
differences I think she also has five
little girls she is chaplain for a local
hospital and I I find it very
heartwarming that the trustees at each
trustee meeting worry about whether
she's getting enough physical support to
do while she's doing and feel some
obligation to make sure that that's in
place for her so they like the
two-for-one they like caring ahead
mistresses wife who was active invisible
and a nurturing part of the team but she
also has her own professional but she
also has her own professional career and
the five little girls are very visible
in and very much a part of that role
and I think it's I think it's a mark of
the times that now these trustees feel
obligated to be sure that she's getting
some some good sturdy physical health
well that raises the issue also if
you've talked about the role of women
students in MIT what about women faculty
indeed what do you think happens at the
Institute to women faculty over the
years I was impressed with how
supportive they were of each other I
through those 10 years was invited to
meet with the women faculty I think it
was sort of every six or eight weeks
they got together for lunch and a
two-hour discussion period and talked
about their problems and working were
candid wanting the administration to
know what they perceived as the most
difficult problems and was supportive of
each other I don't know who that's
continued or not but I hope it has
because it's something that always needs
to be pushed to the forefront when when
people are interviewed for jobs if
there's a qualified woman in there
people need to really be pushing to look
at that woman those numbers need to be
worked on all the time without just of
them as the minority numbers do do you
want to talk a little bit about Paul's
interest in those issues of women and
minorities well that was that was a
passion and I think he always felt that
it was he was thrilled when when a
position was filled by a woman or a
minority but I think he felt that with
all the effort it it still fell short of
where he would have liked it like the
numbers do have been mm-hmm did you feel
when you met with the women faculty that
you were able to to help a
the administration think about ways to
be more supportive in several ways they
talked about things that I knew he
wasn't hearing about and clearly that
was one of my roles that was one of the
reasons they wanted me there was to
carry the message home and that was a
that was a very easy straightforward
thing the other part of that was that
there were times when I felt that they
were perhaps being a little unfair being
agitated about an issue that they hadn't
really explained to the administration
Paul and and his team didn't know what
they were thinking and you can't always
act if you're not informed and so the
other part of what I hoped was a helpful
role was to nudge them to make
themselves clearly determined to make
themselves clearer to appoint a group of
people to go in and talk with Paul and
the provost and and to get the cards on
the table mm-hmm did you feel that were
there times in meeting with the faculty
that you felt that they didn't
understand you know that they were not
as appreciative of the job that you were
doing as they might have been was not an
issue I'm unprofessional because there's
no suspect it was I suspect it was I
suspect
that no one would ever would ever say it
but I suspect but they thought that my
job and my role was a strange one and
one that they would not have done you
know it was not they did not perceive it
as a career professional role that's
right you know did you wish sometimes
that you were in a professional role
would you have changed and in what they
would consider a professional role
because I consider your role a
professional one although not
defined that way that's a hard question
because Paul and I've always been a team
and so I can't imagine being pulled in
any other direction
I did what I what I should have been
doing in those 10 years I have no
regrets with that I did find it hard to
never have time to be spontaneous and I
did finally set several priorities that
were my own priorities the embroidery
the work at Children's Hospital you want
to talk just had to do because I needed
to do something that was all yours
yes that was my interest do you want to
talk about the embroidery because that
brings in the Women's League and a very
social wears it certainly does that that
goes back the embroidery goes back to
being signed up with Renee fells classes
back in 1968 while we were on sabbatical
friends signed us up when Renee and her
husband her husband was at Harvard and
when they decided to retire when they
asked if I would take over the class and
at first I thought that that I wasn't
prepared and then I thought if I don't
try I'll never know and it turned out to
be just a wonderful thing and then as we
moved into the president's house the
general reaction was we can't teach
anymore and that was a little bit like
waving a red flag at a ball the bad word
was can't and I didn't quite understand
why I couldn't the league didn't seem to
have any problem with it and I didn't
have any problem with it and indeed it
was just it was an absolute mental
health kind of thing for me I went in
and for those two and a half to three
hours I was doing something I loved both
both a creative thing and teaching I
guess
teaching really is is the profession
I've always had and I met such an
incredibly wide group of people across
the Institute it was it was a wonderful
experience I met people I never would
have known any other way it was it was
the thing that that made it possible for
me to say I was never isolated because I
had staff people I had people at with
janitors cooks faculty wives faculty
undergraduates graduate students foreign
students wise it was just the most
incredible cross-section of people and
and I've treasured that experience well
I think you began by talking about love
of people as being a an essential
attribute of the job and it's certainly
your love with people's it certainly
seems to have been manifest in every
comment you have made during the course
of our talk and I know that you have too
that your love of people is getting you
and your sense of responsibility means
that you have to leave for your
embroidery class is a stitch in time yes
we're back stitching yeah Thank You
Edith very much thank you it's been a
very pleasant hour well I loved it so I
just have enjoyed it very much so
okay because I think Priscilla I know
you have a few more minutes and I can't
resist picking up on something that
relates on how people perceived your job
and I know that you had some
unusual experiences do you want to tell
about one of them well there was several
that standout eateth they really had to
do with both not taking yourself too
seriously but having some sense of
yourself too we had had a change in
godness and more and more I was able to
have a chance to do flowers which had
not been a popular idea with a woman
named Frances Driscoll who lived there
in the house and she retired and the new
gardener came along and I decided that I
would like to give it a try it always
loved arranging flowers and I thought
that would be a wonderful thing to do so
I took myself all over the Winston's and
I bought my cut flowers and I signed a
bill and as I signed the bill he said
you must be the new housekeeper working
over at the press MIT president's house
how are they the work for and I said
gave us very high Mike's I said that
they were just great to work for and
without laughing and and Paul Paul
chuckled about it for weeks we just
really enjoyed that
that summer I represented MIT at the
dedication of the new wing of the MFA
you may remember that Barbara Bush came
to give the dedication speech and
someone let me off at the entrance and I
got caught in the revolving door and it
wouldn't stop I couldn't get out I
couldn't get out on the outside I
couldn't get out on the inside you'd
become a revolutionary that's right and
suddenly this huge burly man sort of
pluck me like a mother cat would pluck
her kitten literally out from
this revolving door wedged his body and
got it stopped
got me out kind of shook me and stood me
up and looked at me and then turned to
governor king who was governor of
Massachusetts at that time and said look
governor
it's the housekeeper at the MIT
president's house and that he thought
that because the governor is an ex
officio member of the corporation and
for each corporation meeting he would
Breeze him greet all these people open
the meeting with brief remarks and leave
and this body God had spent a great deal
of time out in the kitchen with me
checking on what was for breakfast and
helping that be a crumb leftover and he
never ever did get clear in his mind who
I was and so we've had many laughs over
that
but I was very glad he was there at the
MFA dedication that they to rescue the
housekeeper from the there's your sense
of humor yeah kept you and held you in
good stead that's right
bet it to life right right